i did it uh
13 days in a row i'd hold a load every
day
and so on day 13 i had that little thing
in my stomach i have
a warning we all do like watch out watch
out don't do it so i asked this guy walk
in
it hair lip guy just ugly man i said
joaquin
are you sure this place yes i'm paying
the federalists off no problem no
problem
this is i mean this is the same routine
you're taking every day yeah
you're you're you're used to it 13 times
on the final day
yeah what no final i was i was on a roll
they had marijuana stacked up by
tons okay so i'm just holding all i can
hold out of there right but this guy uh
pedro would get in the plane with me and
joaquin would tell him where he was
going to block a highway
sometime it'd be 20 30 40 miles away and
i would
uh pedro get in a plane with me he was
light and we'd take off and go over and
there would be a two-ton truck blocking
the highway with
rifle or machine gun on it and about a
mile down the road would be another one
blocking the highway so i was on a major
freeway well why now why did they block
the highway that was my runway
holy so no cars could come
and so i'd land they'd put 1100 pounds
in that plane and all it was like a
bucket brigade off the truck
i'd shake hands with all the mexicans
with their sombreros and i'd get back in
the plane take off over the next flood
without
oh my god every day we did it in a
different place on different highways
so uh on day 13
i had the bad feeling all night long it
was just like ooh
i i have that i just have a gift of it
it was just like oh my
and the next morning i went down and
brushed my teeth just at daylight
and uh 10 or 12 men walked down with me
and i got an airplane pedro got in and i
fired it up and it went wow
i thought a tire busted i just looked
over leisurely did i have a busted tire
and pedro's yelling police see a police
seal police seal
and i'm not at the end of the strip i'm
up part way about halfway it's only got
about four 500 feet in front of me
i usually just go there and taxi back
down and turn around
so i just put put the power to
right to the firewall cold engine and on
just went tearing off down
down the end of that strip and when it
got to the end of it i was
doing about 40 50 miles an hour and i
rotated and when i did
there was four of them two on each side
and they just shredded that airplane
with machine guns
there was 80 bullet holes in there and
they shot me down
and uh all the windows was shot out i
was shot across the top of my head my
knee and my toes shut
off the nail up and uh what were they
shooting you from
from both sides of the runway from the
ground from the ground and see i just
run between them right as i went to lift
off
your spray they just riddled it it
looked like one in bunny and clyde cars
so uh i
i went into shock i reckon because the
world just turned yellow
and time slowed down and the gasoline
was just pouring in on me where the
bullets
had gone up into the tanks above my head
and the windshield was out
and a bullet had hit the strut right in
front of me and
pieces of splinters that was all in my
face and my chest
and i just saw ahead of me
in the river the cliff was coming quick
and it looked like in the river it was
on your knee or less
with stones and they was big as this
table looked like great turtles just in
the daylight
was in there and i thought i'll i'll
crash on top of those and maybe i can
live
in the water so i just pulled the power
and
i didn't have no control over the yoke
whatsoever over the
elevators and it
went straight in and when it did on the
first hit the wings came off and the
second hit
the nose came and went underneath the
airplane and i'm sitting there i guess i
was knocked unconscious from the joke
and pedro was shaking like come on roger
come on roger come on roger
and i just stepped out over the nose of
the plane right onto the into the water
of the river
and those feather rallies was coming
they were still shooting it so a couple
of them hit the plane
and there was a pistol in there later on
i used to carry a pistol to start with
and i found it more trouble than it was
worth
but anyhow that morning i had one and a
nine millimeter browning and i just
reached and pulled it out of his holster
because now the radio where it was taped
to is upside down so it's just right
there and i popped a few caps at those
guys and they ran into rocks
and so we took off and then i saw that
pedro's foot was nearly shot off it was
just
and it wasn't bleeding all that bad it
was just like white
and so i took my t-shirt off and tied it
we went on up the
up the mountain and there was an old
donkey looked like she was 30 years old
she way back and he knew her charlotte t
charlotte and he read and we jumped on
that donkey without a bridle or saddle
and we rode i understand now it was
seven miles and we came to a little
house in a clearing and there was a
small man
and he was plowing and he had a a little
horse hooked to a little cow
and the two of them with a wooden yoke
across their back was pulling a little
plow
in some among some stumps and he was
trying to make a living out of a
burn place like this the natives do that
sometimes
and we went in his house and his wife
and his daughter
put some cloth on my wounds and poured
diesel all over it
to keep the flies off diesel fuel diesel
fuel yes
and so he took off and he was gone all
day and late that afternoon
a bunch of horses and mules come
trotting up into the yard
and there was a doctor there dr benjamin
soso a red dot
a red cross doctor and he gave us a shot
of morphine and
tetanus shots and he tried to find the
bullet i still have one in my foot
and he looked for it and he said we had
to get to hospital
and pedro would die if he didn't get to
hospital
they had killed one person on the ground
they tried to run away that morning
so they took us to a road we rode a long
way on on their mules and
we got to a truck it was a two-ton
ten-wheeler
loaded with corn in the ear so they dug
holes on one side for me and holes on
the other side for him and
buried us down in that corn and covered
us up and they kept a little place for
my face
but that was a real rough road and every
time that truck would roll one side the
other
the corner rolled in on me and they had
laughed and take it back off my face
and we went through three road blocks
and they said they had platoon of
soldiers and over a hundred of them
looking for an american
shutdown believed dead and so we got to
the highway after some miles and
went into a house and had a white pan
and
they just kept changing the water i
think i changed it 20 times before i got
the blood and all the
it all for me from that episode on that
last
on that last story you told where you
got shot down by the by the
federales and you got you you you got
shot in the toe
and the knee and then the top of the
foot and across the top of the head and
top of the head
um after you went and got all fixed up
and you were getting transported through
with the corn and
where did you eventually end up after
all that i went to guadalajara and got
on an airplane and flew back to los
angeles
okay and mari took me to wilmington
where i got medical care in the hospital
there
okay how old were you at that point was
that when then was that your first time
actually being shot at no the revenues
had shot at me back
in georgia before the who the federal
revenue was back in georgia when i was
making whiskey
they shot him eight of them shot emptied
their bullets that their pistols at me
in your plane no i was on the ground
running oh
from a whiskey liquor still holy
[Music]
yeah they meant they mean to kill you
they don't care if they got a badge and
a gun and you
you don't do what they say they'll just
kill you right it's like all right we
got a license to kill him
but it was your first time actually in
the trans when you when you got into the
transporting business flying
drugs back and forth was the first time
that you encountered any kind of
resistance
yes and so after you get back home to la
and and uh you're with mari you get
fixed up at the hospital
and i'm sure your wife's trying to
convince you to stop doing this right
no particularly i was pretty cool about
it we
we went to hawaii and i had to put my
foot up in a on a crutch
so i had to keep it higher in my head
for a month or two that thing throbbed
and so the children bring me pina
coladas at the hotel in hawaii and
then we went to uh how bad did your foot
get messed up in that shot that wasn't
that bad it just took
took the toenail off the top of the big
toe and
one slug got into the foot and went
right back at the joint a part of a
bullet
okay so i wouldn't hurt bad i mean to be
nick to be
she could have been killed and one
scraped right across the top of your
head
yeah i got scar right across where it
went across the top of my head
wow
[Laughter]